ryan giggs has spent most of his life in
the spotlight he came to court to hear a
prosecutor describe his football skills
as abundant and a thing of beauty but
off the pitch in his personal life a
character that was much uglier and more
sinister
what they described as a toxic
relationship with his girlfriend kate
greville culminated in an argument at
their home in november 2020 as she tried
to end the relationship the prosecutions
say he deliberately head-butted her and
elbowed her sister in the jaw
peter wright qc said mr giggs was
obsessive controlling and coercive
this was a private life that involved a
litany of abuse he said both physical
and psychological of a woman he
professed to love a woman who in reality
was if the evidence is to be believed
treated in a way that cannot be excused
or overlooked by either an adoring
public or the law this is a story of
control and coercion of a woman who
thought she was loved and respected
sadly the reality was very different
the prosecution said kate greville
described various events over the years
where mr giggs would harass her
threatening to send photographs of a
personal nature to friends and
colleagues throwing her out of their
home there were acts of violence and
volatility mr wright said followed by
kindness and contrition calculated to
gaslight her into doubting herself and
her instincts
ryan giggs is one of the most decorated
players in football history 13 premier
league titles in more than 20 years with
manchester united and until november
2020 the manager of the welsh national
team
the trial was told it may hear from his
former united manager sir alex ferguson
before court ended for the day the
barrister for mr giggs told the jury he
and kate greville had squabbled like
teenagers but that he'd never used
unlawful violence the allegations he
said were based on distortion
exaggeration and lies any contact
between their heads he said was minor
and accidental
brian giggs denies the charges against
him and the trial continues greg milam
sky news manchester